we're here at the London Film and comic
convention and we've got a face-off
between Batman and Batman who's gonna
win I will I think that'll be me I'm not
a hero so I will win it's not who I am
underneath that's what I do that defines
me guys suppose the inspiration for
coming as Batman he's the best character
in the world
he doesn't need powers he doesn't need
heat vision he doesn't have to fly he
just has his wits and his physical skill
he is feasible anyone can be him it
doesn't take the wrong man to do it you
just gotta have the right skills inside
you because like he said he doesn't have
superpowers he's just a man with money
and lots of money and more money but he
has wit he went in the League of Shadows
like myself and we chained together and
that's how you come a real Batman yeah
that's right a real Batman my worst
enemy is the Joker because I don't care
about myself it's about the people of
Gotham and he says that they're all
unholy but I say no he is the worst
psychological I don't care if I get
killed I don't get my back it's broken
by Bane because what I worry about is
people and people of Gotham Batman are
you gonna come out the other side of The
Dark Knight Rises hell yes
you